hi everyone sorry again for the
technical difficulty earlier so I hope
now everyone can see everything ok no
echo so let's let's jump straight to the
news and so the news of this week so we
have new devices so we just announced
this this week the Nexus 4 is a
quad-core Snapdragon s4 with the
Snapdragon processor with a gorgeous 4.7
inch screen and it has NFC actually
which is what we are going to talk about
today we have also another new devices
is a 10-inch device as a super-high
resolution for this 2560 and so I'm sure
you guys can read more about these two
devices on the Internet and of course
the new version of Android 4.2 is we
just announced it and along with that we
have some also pretty good guidelines of
how to build tab like high quality
tablet applications and also in general
like high quality applications so we we
add some more documentation guidelines
to help the help developer to build high
quality applications another major news
we have we now have seller support in
India you can read more about that in in
the blog post but just want to clarify
something the seller support also
including Apple Inc and and and
subscriptions also included the Google
plastics experiment we we announced
earlier so we we still need together
or other other other submissions and we
will followup with you guys next week so
stay tuned so now back to our
presentation this week which is NFC so
let's let's take a look take a look at
what NFC is just before we dive into the
the implementation details so let's take
a high-level overview of what NFC is so
NFC stands for near field communication
it's really based on the RFID technology
is is a strong is a short-range
technology so usually when the device or
or the device to the to the to the NFC
tag card is between like four centimeter
or less communication will start
happening you can also share a small
payload usually in kilobytes betweens
NFC tags and an Android device or or
between like Android devices so the the
most common data format people use for
NFC is the is end F so we were taught of
a little bit more about that in future
slides so what is NFC for actually you
can use NFC Forum couple things are the
first one is show show I mean you can
share contact information using a have
NFC which is one of the most common use
case and and also you can use NFC to do
post trapping for Bluetooth and Wi-Fi
connections so anyway we'll talk a
little bit more about that and also the
Android technology Android Beam so
anyway we'll we'll cover that in the in
later on and the third use case of NFC
is in commerce
so example like content next payment
like Google Wallet but that is a little
bit different
out of our topic today so because uh
Google Wallet kind of requires the
access to the secure element and and if
you're interested in become a partner of
Google Wallet you can you can go to the
link below here to to to to send us
informations so but that's not something
we're going to cover today Google Wallet
but it's a way we are going to focus on
the technology today so for NFC or there
are a few communication protocols so so
these are the protocols so I'm not going
to to spell out all these like ISO
standards here but the the key thing
here is we have Android classes to to
implement this like to talk to these
protocols so and so I kind of like
highlight that with the bullets here and
besides the protocol we have different
types of NFC tags and so the the
standard ones like kind of create us
defined that in the NFC Forum are there
four major types and and there are
products actually implementing these
different types so the some of the most
more common ones are probably you guys
see most of the Mifare ones and in the
song the pinnacle one so there are four
major types of tags in in NFC and we
will see have actually tab that's very
nice table to summarize all these like
to put things together so stay tuned and
besides the NFC Forum standards there
are also other types of
tact so the Mifare classic one is is one
of them and so it's it's also very
popular as nxp is using this this time
of tech and it has additional operation
you can do with these tact and we have a
special car satchel for this also called
my fake classics so so what is a and f
so we we talked about formats of data we
use in NFC and and I mentioned and that
is the kind of like the most common
standards so and F actually stands for
NFC data exchange format it's really a
lightweight binary message format and
one thing about end F Lisa ma an end F
message can have many end F records and
and for for data with an application
define payload can be actually
encapsulate in one or more and that
records so let's take a look at the end
DEP record to a comfortable bit more
about that in detail so they and then
that record compose off a header and a
pillow so in the header it has a three
bit
type name format and it also has the
title itself is a is in variable length
is from 0 to 255 bytes and same thing
for the ID is kind of optional and not
very often used and then the payload or
the payload can actually have data up to
2 to the power 32 minus 1 byte so so
that's the structure of the end of
record so here is the the big pictures
like the some kind of summary of all the
relationship between
like all the classes and so so if you
look at this kind of the the NFC stack
so you have any analog things at the
bottom and then you have the different
communication protocol and and two major
types of applications people can build
and so one is using the standard and def
message for vomit and within that you
have the NFC Forum standard type one to
type for our tag and also have the
Mifare classic tag and the stuff in blue
is is actually the class of the Android
classes we have to the implementation
for those of particular types of tag and
and for non end F format applications we
also have the corresponding classes to
allow developer to talk directly through
through the protocol so we have all
these like NFC a class which is
correspond to the iso 1 4 4 3 3 a
protocol and and etc so it's kind of
mapping these raw protocol if if the
application is not using the end dev
data format so that's kind of a nice
summary of all these things together so
so now let's start to talk about like
how Android actually read the Wheaties
tag and then how to dispatch these tag
to to your applications so again the
tomb 2 major like category so one is the
one is attack with it using the end F
format
another one is using the other non non
indefinite so so we have different
action type so it's actually follow
following the order so we first try to
see whether something matched and F this
data format first so we have action go
and F discomfort so if there is a an
activity that match that action so we
will we will route intend to to that
application so we will see some example
of how to set up these like intent
filtering in your application later and
then so back to the picture if if the
end of discovery action is not is we
don't see any like and their format tag
we will fall fall back to the the tag
discover our actions and then to the
attack discover actions so so this is
kind of how the Android system decision
tree to to decide how to dispatch are
all that well or the other other data or
the NFC tag it reads from from the from
the film so now our how to request NFC
access in your application so as you
guys can probably can imagine so this
definitely has something to do with the
manifest
so first things you need to do is to add
a special permission as a Android
permissions on NFC and for filtering
application in Google Play you want to
use the feature use feature tag
specifically specifying the hardware NFC
hardware
so if NFC is really an optional feature
in your application you can consider
setting this for this the require
attribute of course and
and you can also check NFC runtime
availability by I checked by using the
Cathy file adapter method if it's set if
it's equal now tell me that means NFC is
not available you know in that
particular device so um another thing is
you have to set the minimum SDK version
in your application so the minimum SDK
version and that will have NFC support
this API level 9
so in this level we have we will support
action tag discover action and but we we
kind of recommend developers to least
specify that level 10 because it has a
much more comprehensive retry support in
level 10 and also we can do for point
and for program and dev pushing in API
level 14 we we have Android Beam support
and also some other extra methods
convenience method to create and death
records so I guess at least use API
level 10 that's our recommendation so
filtering so let's take a look at how
you set up your activity to to capture
these NFC intense so you can so one of
the actions you can filter by is the NDF
discover action you can in this example
here you can filter by min type so I can
specify like if the mean type is tax
plain plain texts you that's how you
have a data you have a data tag and
specify the mean time that's how you
further NFC message by min type and if
you want to do filtering by URI you can
also do that so it's a different it has
a different data data tag
specifying the host or prefix of your
URL and and the Knicks actions like
tunnel after after the the the dispatch
system couldn't find a match on the end
of discover action we will fall back to
this tack discover action and in order
for this to work your application have
to specify an XML resource file to
specify the list of technology the NFC
10-year reading for your application the
list of NFC technology has to ask use
supporting before your application can
process that NFC tag information so so
in this case here so what you're trying
to say here is your application will
only take NFC tag that that can support
the entire list of NFC technology so
it's a pretty long list of things and I
think in reality you probably you only
want to specify a field because if this
is really a encases so you you're trying
to to find something that support all of
these technology is not it's not all so
so how to do all in in the in the tag
list so so if you specify multiple
resources like like this example here so
you're you're trying to filter something
like if the NFC tag is supporting NFC a
and and and deaf and all is upon NFC B
or and F if both both of them will match
and and your applications can surf both
of these NFC cards so so if you have
also need to use the all semantics this
the way how you define the type list so
um so the another fallback is you you
know using the tech discover in in your
in your activity you you pretty much
just filter by the the tech discover
that actions and and then in you have a
metadata tag specific pointing to the to
the resource XML file so this is how you
include the filtering in your manifest
so I miss so how to obtain information
from the intent so is is pretty
straightforward on there are two ways
you can do it
so um if you want to have a raw NFC tag
you can always do the get possible
parcel level data extra using are
calling the extra tag and it will return
your attack and you can just look
through and getting to find out of these
sub technology but there's also a confer
convenient rate if you know like you're
only like processing NFC tag with the
using the NDF data format you can you
can use the end F messages extra to get
a list of end F message so so the
coasting that here is really an example
of how you you get the end F messages so
you pretty much you get a list of
possible and then we you you and then
you create and then you cast these like
raw messages to to
to the NDF message just look through it
so then the next session are anyways
going to talk about Android Beam
so our past how's it to you anyway all
right thanks Duffy
so to begin with what's Android Beam
it's something that based on something
called NFC and F message push so this is
about pushing messages from an app
that's running on the foreground an
activity that's running on the
foreground to another activity running
on another phone
so that's the pushpot aspect of um well
by the way can you guys see the this sly
when when any would talks I can and you
you can how about you and you can you
see the slide when any were top and you
can you see the slide message but he can
highlight it to see so it's probably not
getting recorded there let me do
something I will share my my desktop
instead okay
all right I think we've got my slides on
the screen now so right as I was
mentioning a NFC is based on n def
message which format and it's basically
n def message like the only explained is
something that contains a zero or more
in Def regards the first record being
something that describes the URL other
contains the URL or the mime type of the
content that your end of message
contains for example if it's an image
you would have something with the image
mind type or if you have text you would
say a sky 8 as the mime type so that's
your zero position end F record in the
end F message now this message with
these records is pushed from one device
when in close proximity and that's the
basic concept of NFC when you bring
devices in close proximity ending your
app is running in foreground and that's
when NFC beam is activated and it stripe
tries to push the message from one
device on to the another one so as a
programmer how do you how do you enable
your app or make your app Android Beam
capable it's quite simple there are two
options were offered how you can do that
the first one is you basically invoke
the method set end F message push so in
your app is running your activities in
foreground you call this method and this
method is usually used if you have sort
of a static data to be pushed for
example you may want to push the link of
your app to download and this is
something static and this is the method
you would use when you have to push that
kind of data the other option is that
you can have your activity implement
something called create ndepth message
callback and so as soon as your activity
then comes into foreground the the
system invokes this method on your calls
your activity back using this interface
and the only method that you have to
implement from this interface is the
create end F message method so this
method is where you have to provide the
implementation of where how you create
the message and return a message from
the method so the frame-up world invoke
the callback and this method is call and
at this point
you should return the created message
end of message so this is more useful
when you want to add some context to
your end F message so depending on what
state your activity is or maybe if you
for example if you are on YouTube and
you have some URL that you're watching
right now which you want to push to the
other guy so there is some context here
and so you would use this implementation
of using a callback and create the end
of message appropriately by using the
context from your activity and embedding
that data onto the message and puzzling
that message through so and when this is
done what you get is a callback called
set end F pushed message complete
callback this is the callback that's
invoke when the system is able to
reliably beam the message to the other
device and so what we discuss here if
you there's a short snippet of code on
how it's implemented very simple code on
create we set the end F message push
call back and this is the the other
implementation which is the
implementation of implementing an
interface callback so we have a method
implemented here called create and F
message which comes from the create end
F message callback at this point what we
do is we construct we construct a and F
message so like we said and F message is
basically an array of 1 on 0 or more and
F records so in this case what we do is
we have this method called create mine
record and this is a custom method so
what create mine record does is
basically creates the first end F record
as the mime type of the data in this
case it's a ASCII is the mime type
because we are sending some test text
across so it what it does is puts the
the mime type as the first end of record
and then uses the rest of the message in
this case it's just a text that says
beam me up and it uses this to add to
the payload of the end F message which
is the records falling from index 1 to
as long as your depends so but the first
record is always the mimetype
and how do you receive this B message so
what we've done till now is we've
created the end F message and when our
activities in foreground the system will
try to be in this message so on the
other device which is in close proximity
you have the NFC you have to filter your
NFC intent action in depth discovered
this will make sure that the system
knows that you are having you have a
component or you have an activity that's
interested in this intent and when you
declare this intent you declare it with
the URL or mine type of interest to you
which means so for example our our code
that we just saw in the last slide was
trying to send you some ASCII text so
you may declare in this when you declare
this in your manifest you may say that I
am only interested in text if there is
an NFC intent with the message that
carrying text I am interested or if
there is NFC message with carrying some
image data I am interested so you
declare also your mind type of interest
so again like you said it should be the
same as the first end of record of the
incoming message because that's where we
kept the mime type of theory of the
message so once you do that and let's
look at some simple code here it is this
is the method that's invoked on on new
intent which is what will get called
when so this method is what we are
invoking on our new intent and so that
means there is an incoming message now
that we are ready to process so what we
do now is using the get extras of the
intent we try to obtain the raw message
which is the end F message and the end
of messages 0 or the beginning element
of the wrong message array and this is
the only element right now so once we
get the end of message what we want
do is the actual message because the
zero element is the mime type or the URL
type what we want to do is get the
payload starting from the zeroth message
so we say message dot end F message dot
get records and we use a method get
payload which will give us the following
records from the mind type following the
mind type record and this is basically
the text message that we had which said
beam me up and this is how you obtain
the message so as you can see it's just
ten lines of code on both sides on both
devices and sending the intent as well
as receiving the intent and your app is
now NFC being capable you may have some
more use cases like Tony discussed how
to set up a handshake for Bluetooth with
NFC and then in this case you might want
to exchange some more data of different
mime type in the two devices if you want
to initiate a Bluetooth connection or if
you want to send across images or some
other sort of text data but in general
this is how NFC works is put the mime
type onto the first record create the
other records with the payload and push
the payload across declare the intent
NFC discovered and then once you have
the in turn in your activity on new
intent you try to process this message
by obtaining the rori card and then
getting the Paylor from the record and
all this happens on foreground and
that's how NFC beam works your app has
to be on foreground so just a use case
here that what may happen sometimes is
that there may be many there may be
multiple applications on the device that
may be interested in listening to NFC
messages incoming messages of a certain
mime type this could be very common for
something like a contact or image or
text there will be multiple applications
so if your application is sending bad
message or is beaming that message and
you sort of want to guarantee the
delivery of the message back to your app
on the other phone what you can do is
use something called application record
and this is Android application record a
this is very simple implementation what
it does is just puts the package name of
your app
in the end f message so which basically
means inside the end F message
everything is an end of record
so this basically means that we are
creating an indefinite part which
contains the package name of our app so
this is to specifically target er app at
the receiving end of the message this
increases the probability that your app
will be the first app to pick up the
message or it's tits you're obviously
intended the receiver of the message so
just to summarize what we saw in terms
of a graphical illustration on the top
you see a device that has the beam
foreground UI activated which means the
device is ready to beam a message at
this point we use the create end F
message method from the create end F
message callback interface to create our
message and send it to the system
adapter we ad NFC adapter so once you
create the message this message is
beamed to the other device using NFC
technology and if you have the intent
action end F discovered on your app this
message will be delivered to your app
and the format of the end of message
would indicate what is the mime type or
the nature of the data in your message
and based on this you will have your
intent filter saying declaring those
mime types and once you see the data you
are able to parse it using getting the
raw record and then looking through the
record to for the payload so this pretty
much summarizes what we have to offer
for our Android Beam right now yeah
that's that that wraps up our live
presentation for today so Tony we can
move to Q&A yes sure
so let's look at the questions we have
on some of the questions we have
on moderator so the first one I see is
from from and the and it and and not
only from Ukraine so I need to offer
eyes users but I don't want them to feel
some data manually so after receiving
and comfort a confirmation you know I
want exactly my app to be started I can
use the app URI like this my app colon
slash slash some data in Gmail client
because it ignores the URI so I the so
we talked about intent filter so I am I
believe in in in the Gmail client I just
standard HTTP URI is actually is working
and so you in your you know application
so one suggestions I can think of is you
can have an intent filter actually
filter by some specific URL so if you if
you if you have some URL you can your
application only your application can
understand so you can you can and you
can use that to filter by that so you
don't you don't need to use a different
kind of scheme so that would be my
suggestions anyway do you have anything
to add on top of that I think that's the
easiest ways to go through is something
that the framework already understands
and the Gmail app understands is the
HTTP URI the other thing I could think
of is maybe your confirmation because
could come as a file which is of your
application type and once the user
downloads the file maybe a patch you
know like an unlocked patch or something
from the user downloads that file your
app is registered to open the file of
that type that may be another way of
handling this so the second questions we
have here is anything new about NFC in
4.2 API level 17 that you are not
allowed to that you are allowed to talk
about arm so
I haven't seen actually uh anything I am
aware of like super new on 4.2 you arm
so I need to double check that and if we
have something that we can we can talk
about maybe we can talk about that in
the in the next or future adl+ so yeah
so I knew it okay why don't you take the
next question I would like to the
question asks from fight engineer Austin
Texas and the question is I would like
to replace the incoming call screen with
a small overlay but it appears that
there is no way to disable the default
incoming call screen in via and have any
creative ways of achieving the desired
result requiring route is a possibility
so I would not comment on what you can
achieve by rooting because I'm not
really familiar and not something we
recommend anyway to our users so there
is yes you are right the phone
application is the standard application
and you can't put textual or graphical
canvas overlays over the top of it
yeah yeah you know the fourth question
is coming from Russia from Anna Anna
Boch F um so I have a positive
experience on Android platform for
porting application built on frameworks
like spring happene ope etc I would like
you happy to continue development of
cooperation in this field with you so
doesn't really seems like questions
right but we are glad actually you have
good yeah
you have good experience with pouring
your applications feel free to leave us
some more comments or some specific
questions in in in G+ in the future if
you have anything so you had just add
something to it I think there are some
open-source projects that are catering
to these frameworks or adaptations of
these frameworks on Android I sure you
know there is something called spring
Android and definitely jetty right this
so there is a web server tiny HTTP web
server or something like that available
for Android and these are open source so
I think it would have any for you would
be to work with these guys spring
Android is a project where you can go
and contribute and yeah so these are
this is how you can look with community
that's one idea of and they would want
to take a did mix one yes so the next
question is from Shiv Shankar Hyderabad
India the question is I need to process
I need the process of changing the
bitrate of an audio file which should be
used on Android SDK so question is not
really clear to me as I get the first
part that process of changing the
bitrate of an audio file so we have
media codecs where you can have an input
buffer and an output buffer and you can
specify the types or the media
properties there and but I don't get the
part where you say which should be used
on Android SDK so I mean do you mean
like what should work on the Android OS
or as we am not really clear maybe if
you can drop us a comment on what do you
want to say with the second part of your
question we'll be able to answer but
just in case for handling audio and
video pipelines you can use you can use
media codec which is available on the
SDK so the next question is from Sweden
from Mac Mac 10 so random users of my
apps maybe one user a day of 200,000
that's a Java IO founder of an exception
permission denied
when calling contacts open file input a
few second later the power reading works
so our Mac and I actually took a look at
the
the links you have and doesn't actually
give us too much information maybe we
really need to look at some code before
we can fully answer this but but one
like idea I can think of maybe is it
possible to have some sort of raising
conditions like that the files actually
really doesn't exist if in certain cases
so that's my kind of guess how about how
about you any rate so anything you can
you can think of I saw the I saw these
factories there maybe if you can obtain
a buck face from the device which will
capture more information on what's
happening I can see there is a
permission denied by the UNIX API is
there but yeah I mean a buttress would
probably help narrowing what's happening
so if you can grab one from your users
maybe even random failure of flash drive
or storage all right so how about the
last question anyone go and take that
sorry so the question is what are the
various best approaches to develop
static pages each page contains text I
think you skip one all right so that's
all right so that's the second loss is
card emulation supported if yes then how
do we do card emulation on Android
devices Google Wallet is able to do why
not other right I don't know the answer
to this one
so Google Wallet I don't know not only
do you have any insights on I I I
believe actually emulation is supported
because I I heard the developer has done
that people and and also like when when
when one Android device talking to
another Android device is really some
sort of like immolations so not hundred
percent sure is is really the true type
emulation but so III have I don't have a
direct answer
so maybe we can we can take a look at
that and get back to you next week
follow up with you is probably not using
the stock a stable set of interfaces
right now to work against NFC in the
sense which can be published as part of
SDK available there will be one so it's
sort of experimental and what it's doing
and once we have some kind of stable
interface that may become a public SDK
facing API you
if the cushion was positive that means
hope like to have push on this API is
that we are talking about I am referring
to see interface which I have been
provided already and has been
implemented in many of the devices such
as Sony devices the seek interface what
we find is that it is not yet human
women taking the first not
that's why it's not to the standard it's
just for people to get some kind of info
if it is going to be in standardizing
pretty future anyways it then the
roadmap or not something like that the
first people want to do something with
the see interface they want to access
the SIM card for certain reasons because
miscue element that's the first thing
they want to access secure resume and
being not able to do is kind of a
limitation for many of the a plan like
that and you guys are having something I
mean definitely there's there's work in
progress even wallet when it when it was
launched and even now it's it was
bundled with specific devices because
like you said it's not a stable
interface right now there are different
implementations across vendors and so
this is something that is being worked
at and I I don't know the timelines on
when we'll have something stable to be
exposed as a backward compatibility API
for all time but there is work in
progress and I can try to find out more
from the teams and update you on what's
what progress is
quality also a small question yeah
Google s used to have compatibility with
this the SWT chip so it was able to have
a communication over there
Google Nexus was access to the previous
one the Nexus 3 with children for Galaxy
Nexus wasn't having it are we expecting
this to be there in Nexus 4
sigh can can you repeat the first part I
didn't really catch with the audio
breaking I'm saying Galaxy Nexus was not
having it yet the Nexus S the previous
one was having the sync interface which
it was having the swp chip so by which
it a sim can communicate upon the NFC
level is there any possibility that
Nexus 4 will be having been standing and
chance I can find out I can find out I
don't know the answer all right so maybe
you can join us next week all for the
answers or we will try to post it'll
keep us on the same thread you try try
to post post a question in ng+ to us
like a just so that we have a record and
we can we can follow up easier so thanks
I'm my ID is under the money and that's
Tony chances you can find us on G+ and
maybe you can just pack us to post a
question and so let's take a look the
last question so so what what our where
is our best approach is to develop
static pages each page contain our tax
and optional images I'm thinking to use
one activity will pager user should feel
like pages of a real boat while the user
flip left and right through pages of
data so I mean depending on the size of
the book that you're talking about 200
pages maybe you don't want 200 fragments
sitting in a viewpager with
the data flipping across so what you
probably want to do is you know
instantiate something with five
fragments and try to buffer or cycle
through your content of the book so
keeping some pages in the buffer so user
can go up and back and then maybe use
just animations on a given fragment or a
view to have the the content of one page
of content of the fragment being
replaced the text and the image being
heat placed from your data source again
yeah I mean I the the strategy of using
an activity of the fragment and some
animations would be good so Google books
itself was written with render script
and under script is a low-level graphics
and mathematical computation library
that we introduced so I'm not sure what
the kind of development you see on it
going ahead but that's what Google Books
was using at that point of time but
again you have the options using Java
OpenGL 3d interfaces and to give those
effects and animations and even the
framework the object animator properties
can give you sort of animation to give
the effect there but yeah I mean I would
look at a fragment with a view
containing text and images and some
animations there well I guess that's
that's all we have in terms of questions
and so thanks thank you very much for
watching and I hope you learn something
about NFC today and so we will be back
next week hopefully anchor we'll be back
- so anyway anything any anything else
you want to add before we just a
reminder that we are going to be running
the Android experiments and the first
one who was about connectivity API so if
you have some last-minute submissions
please go on and if you want to showcase
your code or I have us review it or
showcase what you've done please submit
it to the Android experiment space we
are looking forward to it cool all right
I think that's it thank you very much
for watching and we'll see you next week
all right bye